Hello there, the Internet.
I'm Gavin.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo Guys and
we're filming something
that I've never seen
in slow motion before.
I'm not sure how many
people have in slow motion.
What we've got here is a
number 11, grade 60 rebar.
So it's pure steel beam, basically.
It's one and a half inches
thick, so it's an absolute beast.
We're gonna pull it apart.
Yeah, we're gonna rip it apart.
Using this here machine.
And no, I've been
working my back recently.
Yeah, well first, let's see
if you can pull it apart.
Oh god.
You wanna tug-of-war?
Let's try it.
I don't think we're gonna manage.
So this, apparently, is like,
it has rated to how much
it can be pulled apart.
And this one can pull
apart up to 220 kips,
which is 220,000 pounds
of pulling-apart force.
And we wanna find out
what this'll break at.
What's that in horsepower?
A fleet?
Let's split.
Oh, for goodness sake.
Ready?
Ready.
It has begun.
World's meatiest machine
is doing its work.
The hard part will be...
Is like, guessing the framing,
so I've gone quite wide.
But seeing everything from,
what we got, like 12,
12 little ones there.
We're on 60 kips.
60,000 pounds.
Starting to make noise now.
Yeah, just the occasional creak.
Yeah.
Is this gonna be loud?
I wonder if it'll--
Whoa!
We'll see some visible stretching.
Oh yeah.
What's it at now?
79, 80.
80 kips.
Oh, there's bits falling off there.
Yeah.
Oh god.
We got more kips than frames.
Oh.
I'm really nervous.
Where we at?
105.
Over 100,000.
God!
Oh, it's chipping like that.
Look at the outside.
It's like the inside is stretching
more than the outside can take.
Aw, yeah.
Ooh, I'm scared.
125.
God.
Oh god.
I don't think we're gonna have
the frame rate for this.
Oh, oh!
Oh, the whole machine tipped.
What are you freaking out about?
What are we at?
140.
Thousand.
That's like 10 mega stone.
Mega stone?
I don't know.
Just go!
Any day, now.
Go on, snap.
Oh god.
Look at that stretch!
Oh, oh!
Look at it stretching!
Good lord!
My heart jumped!
Flip!
Lovely, clean break.
157.4 thousand pounds.
God, my heart rate.
Let's see what that looks like.
Whoa!
It gets dark, like a cloud of mist.
Oh man!
That's amazing!
That's the best way to
clean this steel bar,
is to break it in half.
No garbage leftover after that.
Then all the stuff from
above came down later.
Yeah.
Ooh!
God, that went!
Oh, absolutely did, look at this.
This is actually amazing,
'cause this bit's the
bit that actually broke.
It's really warm to the touch.
So like, you start here and it's cold
and it just gets warmer and
warmer and it's just like, hot.
'Cause it's stretched out
the metal so much.
Oh my god!
Yeah.
That's just from the friction,
that's just from the stretching
that it caused all that heat.
That is really cool.
Bloody hell.
So to set the machine up,
before you can start pulling,
it has to like, grip in on either end.
And you can see here where the grips
have just cut into the steel.
And it like, just absolutely,
completely crushes it,
so that you can pull it apart.
And you can see the
little individual notches.
That was hefty.
That was scary.
I jumped.
It's amazing how it just cleans,
it takes like, an entire
layer of itself off.
Well it's mental, 'cause
it was probably about here
and then it just suddenly
went like, whoop.
Bang.
Yeah.
And you can see it's sort of
like, necked in where it broke,
because that was where
it was most stretched.
And even in slow-mo, it was instant.
Absolutely instant.
Yeah.
We probably need a million frames
to get the propagation of that crack.
The machine's just made me
feel completely inadequate.
Well, yeah.
I mean, I can pull what, 10 pounds?
Hopefully, you enjoyed that video.
Feel free to follow us on Twitter.
Subscribe, we got loads of slow-mo,
we got a second channel, we've got merch!
And let us know if you like
these science-related videos.
I do.
I bloody do.
You bloody do?
Bloody love science.
Bloody love it?
Love it.